hey this is a super interesting data
point in trying to figure out how the
YouTube algorithm works and now I want
to preface this by telling you that
YouTube is deliberately and notoriously
opaque about how the algorithm works and
supposedly the reason for this is that
they believe that if people knew exactly
how the YouTube algorithm worked they
would be able to game the system and
unfairly take advantage of that
algorithm for personal gain but even if
that's partially true there are all
sorts of other reasons that YouTube
would be incentivized to keep that
algorithm a secret which includes that a
secret algorithm better enables them to
manipulate or control the specifics of
the algorithm without having to explain
themselves since much like you know
religion and God working in mysterious
ways the algorithm is complex it's
always learning it's always being
modified so one of the areas that's
gotten a ton of talk about YouTube's
algorithm is about monetization
especially with the recent steven steven
crowder Carlos masa situation the
initial nandi monetization of Crowder's
videos then D monetization then I
believe re monetization of Steven
Crowder's content after this incident
where he was participating in anti-gay
bullying effectively of Carlos masa
the topic of what is considered
monetizable by YouTube's algorithm made
a bunch of headlines and a lot of
articles were written about it in the
last few days some youtubers will try to
avoid certain trigger words that we
think caused a video to lose monetized
status other youtubers think that it
really comes down to the topic it's not
so much about the video title itself
there are debates about does the
thumbnail influence whether the YouTube
algorithm will or won't monetize your
videos those are all sorts of the the
debates that exist around monetization
but there's a totally different
conversation about the algorithm which
is how does the YouTube recommendation
algorithm work this is the algorithm
that determines
which other videos will YouTube suggest
to you as you are watching videos on
YouTube website and this is tailored to
each individual viewer based on their
watch history and other elements which
aren't totally clear to us again because
the algorithm is relatively opaque so
for example when I was logged into my
personal YouTube account this morning
not the show account and I watched a
video from yesterday the algorithm
suggested to me a John Oliver video a
good morning Britain video about Trump a
CNN video from a congressional hearing
CBS news video about 2020 democratic
polling a Bill Maher video from years
ago that infamous radical Islam video
with Sam Harris and Ben Affleck and then
a video from Vice about black
conservatives so an open question is how
many of these recommendations are based
on what YouTube thinks I'm most
interested in how much of it is based on
what is most profitable for YouTube to
promote which may not be the same as
what I'm most interested in and does
YouTube have a sort of blacklist and
whitelist whitelist including channels
that YouTube is going to
disproportionately promote merely
because they've decided that that's what
they're going to do I don't know the
answers to any of those questions but I
have a really interesting data point for
you today and it has to do with my
appearance on Joe Rogan's program last
week viewer Alexander wrote to me take a
look at what he said hey David I just
wanted to share an interesting
experience I've had with your channel
after watching you on Joe Rogan last
night watching today's show my
recommended videos are entirely Joe
Rogan scrolling down I count 10 Joe
Rogan videos all before any content I've
watched recently I've only once viewed
Joe Rogan's content and that was last
night now my queue is full of his
content I know you're always looking for
insights into the YouTube algorithm and
I thought I'd share this with you and
Alexander actually sent me a screenshot
of this and indeed while watching our
full show for members video from
yesterday every single recommended video
was from the Joe Rogan experience now
this is fascinating
because Alexander says he has only
watched one Joe Rogan video in his life
and it was the one I was on and it was
yesterday he presumably has years of
YouTube history of watching all sorts of
other things and he watches one Joe
Rogan video and suddenly every
recommendation even when he goes back to
my videos is only Joe Rogan video so
there's a few things that could be going
on here and there are more which I
encourage you to write to me if you
think of them number one YouTube could
have certain channels that it promotes
as soon as someone watches even a single
video because they are in some sense
playing favorites with certain channels
maybe Joe Rogan's channel is a YouTube
favorite because YouTube finds it
profitable YouTube finds that it
increases watch time drastically and
keeps people on the website whatever the
case may be it doesn't have to be
nefarious reasons another possibility is
that Joe Rogan's content is genuinely so
engaging in a way that nothing else is
on YouTube that the algorithm has
determined that as soon as anyone
watches even one Joe Rogan video the
algorithm should show them all Rogan
videos because that is going to lead to
really high engagement and it's going to
keep people on the website and it's not
about playing favorites or a white list
of swords it's just that the content is
that engaging but something about this
is more than random chance or what we
would call like typical algorithmic
behavior watching YouTube for years and
never Rogan you watch one Rogan video
and the next day every single video in
the recommendations feed is a Joe Rogan
video I don't know what we learned from
this but it's interesting
and given the interest in understanding
YouTube's algorithm because it's so
opaque and because it really is an
important thing in determining how much
creators like us make I want to get your
thoughts about this and I want to really
I thank Alexander for taking a
screenshot of that and sending it to me